we're joined today by Jessica Pico who
is a senior legal analyst for rewire a
daily online publication that covers
reproductive justice Jessica in many of
the discussions around the possible
repeal and/or replacement of the
Affordable Care Act there's not been a
lot of discussion at least in the
mainstream about the co-pays for
contraception under the birth control
provisions of the Affordable Care Act
and a lot of reproductive health related
elements so let's start there a little
bit I mean what what is that risk when
we talk about the wholesale repeal of
the Affordable Care Act when it comes to
reproductive health
well what's risked was at risk if we
talk about a wholesale repeal is nearly
everything on let's start with the birth
control benefit for example what it did
was create a fully functional
non-discriminatory coverage for the
first time in the health insurance
industry by allowing birth control to be
considered preventive medicine which it
is and as a result it became part of
essential health services which in which
are basically included in all packages
so that's one component of it it means
for the first time ever the people who
need access to contraception for
whatever reason can have it covered
through their insurance by no additional
cost or copay so they're already paying
that in their monthly deductibles then
there's the potential Medicaid repeal
and we don't talk about that in terms of
a reproductive justice issue but I think
it's really important to wrap that in
because it's not necessarily tied to
contraception specifically but it is
tied to the ability of people of low
income and the disability community
folks to gain access to comprehensive
reproductive health care generally and
comprehensive health care also and
finally there's one more provision in a
called section 1557 which requires that
healthcare providers including including
insurance companies provide
non-discriminatory health benefits
across the board and so this is largely
protected the LGBTQ community from
facing discriminatory care in say
Catholic hospitals so while we can talk
about the birth
benefit certainly is a huge component of
it I think it's important for people to
remember that there are a lot of
components to reproductive health that
are built into the ACA when we talk
about the cost of some of these services
or products when not subsidized or
covered by insurance what are we talking
about I mean I think there's a lot of
people in our audience some some of whom
may not know just based on on being men
and never having been on the purchasing
side of some of these products but also
there may be people who have not availed
themselves of these services recently
HHS Secretary Tom price seems to believe
that there isn't anybody who can't
afford birth control without it being
covered by insurance but what types of
costs are we talking about well I think
when we hear comments like there's not a
single person who can who can who can't
afford birth control what we're hearing
is that men presume that all birth
control is say for example condoms and
something that you can pick up for 10
dollars or so at your local Walgreens
presuming the pharmacist or the person
at the point-of-sale doesn't turn you
away because they have a religious
objection to handing out contraception
so I think those comments are first and
foremost grounded in an understanding
that men use contraception and it's easy
to use contraception the reality is
obviously women use contraception too
and it costs up significantly more money
broadly speaking if we were to talk
about an IUD which is one of the most
effective forms of long-acting
reproductive contraception and we are
talking about a minimum cost at about
eight hundred dollars out-of-pocket
sometimes more and depending on the
variety in ways in which the cost and
the insurance program gets mucked up
that can go even higher a package of
birth control can cost some women under
some plans as much as seventy-five
dollars a month and that may not sound
like a lot to somebody who makes two
hundred three hundred four hundred
thousand dollars but if you're our wage
worker let's say you are someone who
works at a hospital as a care attendant
you are an hourly wage worker or you
make a low salary fifty dollars a month
for a package of birth control pills is
a lot of money
eight hundred dollars at lea
for an IUD is even more and prohibitive
well that's where you get to what I
think is the sort of fundamental
hypocrisy and double standard and if
anything has exposed the fact that many
individuals don't care about double
standards it's sort of been the last six
months of the current administration but
putting that aside for a moment you have
by and large the same political
constituency that says that they are
against abortion in all cases or in
almost all cases wanting not to make
birth control more affordable and more
accessible which has been shown in study
after study to reduce the number of
abortions because it reduces the number
of pregnancies which gets me Jessica
ultimately believing that this is not
really just about preventing abortion
because if it were they would be making
a lot of these birth control and
contraceptives more available and more
accessible it's about people suffering
the consequences for what the right
considers to be immoral behavior isn't
that really what underlies this
inconsistency between on the one hand
saying we want no abortions and on the
other hand not wanting to do what has
been shown to reduce the number of
abortions sure I think that you hit on a
very important point which is that there
is absolutely immoral hypocrisy I would
add to that that there is built within
that moral hypocrisy of belief that
women shouldn't even be working outside
of the home or that are valued enough to
be worthy of non-discriminatory
treatment one of the things that we know
for a fact is that the gendered wage gap
is exacerbated by unintended pregnancies
or even intended pregnancies that bring
women in and out of the workforce and so
to the extent that women are unable to
control the reproductive autonomy to the
extent that anybody is able to control
their reproductive autonomy what that
does is also affect the way that they
can earn a living and the kinds of
earning and earnings that they can make
over the course of a lifetime and so
this is as much an economic attack on
the poor as it is a moral attack on from
certain extreme portions of Christianity
in this country now it seems as though
at least temporarily
the Obamacare repeal has has sort of
stalled putting aside a repeal of the
Affordable Care Act we know about some
of the other ways in which reproductive
health can be attacked and one is the
cutting of funding at the state level to
Family Planning clinics as one example
what are other ways outside of the
repeal of the Affordable Care Act that
access to reproductive health benefits
and contraception can be attacked well
we've seen a swarm of these at the state
level since 2010 whether they are
architectural restrictions like the one
struck down by the Supreme Court or
whether they are waiting periods that
demand patients go visit a doctor and
then wait twenty-four forty-eight or
eight or in some cases 72 hours before
going back to another to the to the
doctor to actually have the procedure so
that adds cost it adds time and distance
I mean if you've got to arrange for
child care if you have to take time off
from from work and then I think also we
have to pay attention to the attacks on
the front doors of the clinics because
they are rising it's enough that we have
patients navigate a myriad of
legislative restrictions on abortion
access but then in many cases we force
them and their companions to walk
through throngs of protesters that are
calling them terrible name calling them
[ __ ] calling them baby killers and and
sometimes these are you know patients in
need of completed miscarriage or
terminating a pregnancy that was very
much wanted or you know a pregnancy
Silver's and and yet at the same time
this matters not to the people who are
protesting the clinics they cannot be
the difference
yeah I've been covering that quite a bit
it's absolutely deplorable behavior from
from a free speech and censorship
perspective how can you manage that in
other words without infringing on one's
of right to be out in public and
speaking or holding a sign that they
want at what point do we do we have to
say well this there's here the gray area
here's where you're on one side of it
and here's where you're clearly on the
other side of just free speech in public
I think that's a really fair question
and I think you know rewire has released
a short documentary called
Karen chaos that talks and explores this
protest movement in the way it affects
the front door of clinics and in that
film is a focus on the only clinic in
Fargo North Dakota and the law
enforcement officer there and I think
that she does a really good job of
balancing as the film shows the protest
rights of those who oppose abortion and
the rights of doctors and providers and
patients and their companions to safely
and securely access their constitutional
right to an abortion I think the other
thing that's important to remember and
gets lost in the speech kind of context
and was mentioned by Justice Stevens and
one of his abortion related decisions
that for buffer zones they didn't quite
get struck down but that there is also
the right to be left alone and we've
seen this in some of the cases involving
say for example the Westboro Baptist
Church where there are protest rights
that you also as an individual have a
right to not be compelled to listen to
speech that you don't want to and I
think that this is an issue that we need
to revisit as we see an amplification of
these protestors and them and their
tactics getting again more radicalized
and more direct I don't think this is
the thing that will go away and so I
think it is time to revisit and reinsert
into the conversation the right to be
left alone because it exists in the
Constitution the First Amendment
recognizes it and it's an important
component all very very important issues
spanning really a lot of different types
of legal and cultural questions we've
been speaking with Jessica Pico senior
legal analyst for rewire which is a
daily online publication covering
reproductive justice Jessica thanks so
much for talking to me today thank you
so much for having me on